hi my name's Bandit you might be
wondering where the I've been allow
me to explain when tears of the Kingdom
released I'm sure that all or at least
most of you watching right now joined me
in no life in this game for the
following several weeks I even streamed
it a few times so you know huge thanks
to those of you who watched me play the
game over on Twitch the more I played
the game though the more I was made
aware of just how many questions about
the story and lore of the franchise were
answered but also raised or left
untouched altogether and in this video
I'd like to focus our attention on the
several topics that are still left
completely unanswered and up to
speculation even months after the game's
release oh and spoiler alert obviously
the first question that everyone had
going into the game that still persists
after the ending is who and what are the
zonai really now tears of the Kingdom
did answer a lot of questions regarding
the zonai in the first place it
confirmed their existence when it was
all just speculative theories before and
it showed us that they were an ancient
highly Advanced people group that
descended upon Hyrule from the sky guys
above and their Technologies and
artifacts such as the secret Stones were
so Advanced that the early hylians
regarded them as Gods interestingly
enough though the zonai we meet in tears
of the kingdom are nothing like the more
barbaric zonai that we thought we would
meet based on speculations from breath
of the wild but that's neither here nor
there by the time of the games back in
time time frame which I will just refer
to as the birth of Hyrule time frame
since apparently Zelda gets sent back to
the beginning of the kingdom of Hyrule
there are only two zonai left in the
world according to Ganondorf which would
be king raru and his sister minaru and
that is about all we know about the
zonai we still don't know where they
actually come from or why they all left
the world in the first place or where
they went or if they still exist today
or how they were able to create these
powerful artifacts called The Secret
stones that enhance a user's power
levels far beyond what they normally are
capable of or why they even created
these stones in the first place
especially since they made them long
before Ganondorf revealed his true evil
intentions why did they take an interest
in hylians at all just to leave them
with technology and all powerful secret
stones that led to the world being
threatened by evil it almost sounds like
a retelling of the creation story which
is to say the three golden goddesses
that created the world and left the
omnipotent Triforce behind directly led
to all of the good versus evil conflicts
to come and furthermore if raru and
minoru are around the birth of Hyrule
and their zonai people have already come
and gone from the world then where were
they in Skyward Sword which takes place
before the surface of the world is
inhabited or did they all arrive after
scared sword and then leave before the
birth of Hyrule or was the birth of
Hyrule before Skyward Sword and the
kingdom dissolved by the events of
scared sword only to be founded again
after Skyward Sword there's just so much
we don't know yet but moving on the
second question that remains unanswered
is what is Ganondorf how is Ganondorf
why is Ganondorf chokes aside though why
do he do what he do in tears the kingdom
why does he threaten the kingdom of
Hyrule there's no Triforce to fight over
and he didn't even know about the
existence of the omnipotent secret
Stones until he was already actively
attacking the kingdom not to mention he
had no idea who or what hylia and Zelda
are so what gives without any other
insight into his motivations behind
betraying King Robert and trying to take
over Hyrule it's left to just be a
simple Command and Conquer explanation
for his actions which if I'm honest
feels very Hollow especially since
Ganondorf in the past has had such a
rich and almost relatable backstory and
motivation to his actions one that in a
certain light might almost be considered
Noble with this being the first
canonical appearance of Ganondorf
dragmire in the series in over 17 years
it leaves a lot to be answered here's
hoping that we get more Ganondorf and
early Gerudo lore in the inevitable DLC
speaking of ganondorf's motivations by
the way at number three we've got to ask
yet again where is the Triforce
seriously though where is it at least in
breath of the wild we had that flash of
the Triforce symbol when Zelda used her
powers which left some people not me but
some people satisfied with the
speculation that the full Triforce now
resides inside of Princess Zelda somehow
in tears of the Kingdom though we
literally do not have a single mention
or even flash of a symbol of the
Triforce anywhere I mean unless you
consider rauru's weird triangle hand
pose that he strikes whenever he uses
his powers to be a Triforce reference
but even then that is super vague I
personally found it rather strange that
the Triforce would not be mentioned even
back in the birth of Hyrule time frame
which is when the Triforce was
definitely a thing the Triforce has been
the Catalyst for the conflicts and
stories of most if not all of the main
lines Zelda games so to have its last
appearance be 10 years ago in A Link
Between Worlds is
strange especially when characters like
Ganondorf that normally fight over the
Triforce are brought back but without
this key piece of their normal story
arcs but I digress moving on at number
four I pose the question of who or what
are the other dragons assuming you've
beaten the game or that you haven't yet
but you're okay with spoilers since
you're still watching at this point we
find out that in order to transform into
a dragon the likes of which look exactly
like dinroll farash and nadra you have
to consume a zonai secret Stone and the
process is irreversible well unless you
have the power of plot armor on your
side but that's neither here nor there
since we never got anything on the three
Golden Dragon's origins in breath of the
wild it could then theoretically be that
they used to be individuals who ingested
secret zones just like Zelda and
Ganondorf did the question is then who
was it that ingested the stones were
they Ancient zonai Ancient hylians the
golden goddesses themselves there's no
way of telling whether this was even the
case so it remains unanswered number
five who was the ancient hero of the 10
1000 year old Calamity now we finally
got some insight into this ancient
red-haired hero who wielded the master
sword ages ago but again in classic
tears of the Kingdom fashion it really
just ended up bringing up even more
questions once you finish all 152
shrines and tears of the Kingdom which
is up from the 120 in breath of the wild
you are gifted with the ancient Heroes
aspect which literally transforms link
into the ancient hero of the Calamity
and as you can see it's a zono complete
with the snout zonai armor and markings
and Link's iconic blue blue eyes the
thing is though we've always known that
the spirit of the hero reincarnates as a
different link from era to era to
Vanquish evil alongside hylia's
descendant known as Zelda at no point
has link ever not been a Hylian but then
there's this randomly in the middle of
hyrulean History the spirit of the hero
was a zonai and let me be clear just
because the Calamity of ten thousand
years ago was ten thousand years ago
does not mean that it was the origin of
time or anything even close to that as a
reminder it is Canon according to both
in-game information and extracurricular
information from Masterworks creating a
champion that the events of the distant
past which is the history pre-dating the
10 000 year old Calamity tells us the
story of other Zelda games like Ocarina
of Time directly referencing the
adventure of the hero of time and Zora
Princess Ruto and remember that
according to Ganondorf all of the Zone I
had left the World by the time of
hyrule's birth and King raru's Reign so
why and how is one hero somewhere smack
dab in the middle of the timeline
randomly azonai sounds to me like we
need a game detailing the events of the
10 000 year old Calamity more than
anything else next at number six we have
to ask is malice gloom and if so why are
they different and if not how did that
switch happen according to the teardrop
memories Ganondorf was sealed Away by
the power of rauru's swirly green light
at the beginning of the kingdom of
Hyrule it is then implied that the
powerful dark substance known as Gloom
leaked out of Ganondorf in the years and
ages to come and gave rise to the
Calamity ganons we know of from breath
of the wild or did it see Calamity Ganon
which was said to have originated from
underneath Hyrule Castle hint hint was
created from a similar substance known
as malice which also is the substance
responsible for capturing all of the
sheikah war machines in breath of the
wild the blood moon in breath of the
wild is also a phenomenon said to paint
the sky red with ganon's malice but in
tears of the Kingdom malice is nowhere
to be found and the blood moon still
happens but now it's Gloom that paints
the sky red and Gloom that has created
all of ganondorf's monsters even the
ones showed to us from way back when in
the beginning of the kingdom of Hyrule
so originally Ganondorf The Demon King
used Gloom but then Ganondorf The Demon
King used malice which is very similar
but then Ganondorf The Demon King went
back to using Gloom again after a little
while it's kind of confusing number
seven speaking of Gloom though one of
the first things we see in the game
that's also one of the most shocking
images to ever come from The Legend of
Zelda as a franchise would be the
shattering of the master sword now I'm
gonna go on a mini rant and I apologize
in advance for doing so but for those
who have have been fans of the franchise
since before breath of the wild you'll
know that the master sword is more than
just a really powerful sword it's more
than an extremely powerful sword it is
the blade of Evil's vein and according
to raru not this raru but the original
rauru from Ocarina of Time it is a blade
which evil cannot even touch we even see
it happening in Twilight Princess it is
Ultimate in its power and can even kill
a Triforce empowered individual such as
Ganondorf not this Ganondorf but the
ganondor from Twilight Princess who
previously had cheated death via the
power of the Triforce of power implying
that the master sword's sacred ability
trumps even that of the Triforce so when
we saw that the sword was to be broken
in tears of the Kingdom our thoughts and
theories ran wild what could possibly
exist in the world that could even
remotely harm the blade of Evil's Bane
turns out it was just Gloom which is a
substance that's largely unexplained
which when you reclaim the restored
Master Sword later in the game is no
longer able to shatter the blade now I'm
not upset by this just a little
disappointed that the sword wasn't
broken for I guess a bit more Grandeur
of a reason but that's just me ranting
rant over the actual unanswered question
here is why wasn't the blade able to
just have its Gloom recalled out of it
if you've been on my channel for a while
I predicted that recall would be used to
somehow restore the Master Sword to its
former glory however I did not know that
when used here recall would really just
rewind the world around the blade back
in time to the birth of Hyrule instead
of recalling the blade itself which if
it had done for oh a period of 24 hours
or so would have actually repaired the
blade and removed the effects of Gloom
from it a good question I say moving on
question number eight is why did rauru
begin building shrines of light before
ganondorf's attack we can see in the
mulguera raid cutscene that there are
already shrines of Light present across
Hyrule and these shrines are meant to
provide a chosen hero with lights of
blessing that according to raru are
meant to purge evil but prior to
Ganondorf revolting against Hyrule here
there was no threat to the land did
Zelda advise the king to begin building
these shrines was there some sort of
prophecy that foretold and eventual evil
was raru bored we may never know but we
can always assume at number nine I have
the smaller question of whether or not
the old DLC or amiibo items from breath
of the wild such as the Majora's Mask or
the hero of time tunic or the fierce
deity sword are now considered Canon
within the world of Tears of the Kingdom
which would mean that they are also
canon in the world of breath of the wild
each of these items are from earlier
games that have taken place tens of
thousands of years ago and again were
only introduced to the world of breath
of the Wild's Hyrule by way of DLC or
real-life amiibo TAPS in tears of the
Kingdom though we have every one of
these fourth wall breaking items present
in actual locations scattered throughout
the depths in various caves across
hyrule's surface in game some of which
have been placed there by misco the
great Bandit so this begs the question
are these items Canon and does this mean
that the amiibo Taps are all Canon which
means that Epona the horse of Legend is
Canon or wolfling from Twilight Princess
is Canon and if so how in the goddesses
Green Earth are each of these Priceless
World altering relics located where they
are in the present day and if they're
not canon does that mean that misco the
great Bandit is non-ganon where does
that end something tells me that if your
name isn't agio Numa you may never know
the answer now before we reach the final
unanswered question from the game I did
have a few honorable mention questions
that aren't big enough to Warrant their
own place on the list such as is
ganondorf's gloomy leaky corpse that's
been down there since the birth of
Hyrule apparently the reason behind all
the evil in the franchise AKA is
ganondorf's corpse the literal curse of
demise and if so does his actual death
at the end of the game mean that the
curse is broken and that there is no
more evil to come in the future ending
the timeline what about why did rauru's
hand randomly fall off of Ganondorf at
the exact moment that Lincoln Zelda
approached it and if it had run out of
power then why was it Stone still fully
powered when Zelda picked it up oh and
finally if Sonia and raru are Zelda's
ancestors where is their child since
Ganondorf kills Sonia on screen that
must mean that their child is Alive and
Well somewhere in order for Sonia's
bloodline to continue on and Zelda
eventually but why is there no mention
of a child anywhere in the game even
Zelda's mother which has never been
present in either game was mentioned
several times in breath of the wild but
anyway back to the list finally at
number 10 we have perhaps the biggest
question in all of Tears of the kingdom
and that is if Zelda and mineru and the
rest of the early sages raised the great
Sky Island into the sky in order for the
hero to eventually revive they are far
above ganondorf's reach does that mean
that they raised all of the other Sky
Islands as well I mean that would make
sense since they all appear Suddenly at
the exact moment Zelda travels back in
time and are not present in the birth of
Hyrule cutscenes but the first question
obviously is why did they raise all the
other Sky Islands if link was only meant
to resurrect on the great sky island and
the second question is if these Sky
Islands were raised out of the work of
Zelda slash minaru and the sages which
as a reminder is when only two zonai
were left in the world how then did the
zonai youth use the diving islands for
testing bravery according to a steward
construct isn't that contradictory to
the fact that the zonai were not present
in the world at the point of these
islands being raised into the sky
meaning there could not have been any
zonai youth using them to test their own
skills regardless of how many questions
are or are not left unanswered after
playing this game that has absolutely
nothing to do with how amazing it felt
to play Tears of the Kingdom I just
wanted to specify that since I do really
really like the game in case some of you
were doubting that since I made this
video with that out of the way though
what do you think are there even more
questions that I didn't think of or have
some of these actually been answered and
I just missed the explanations let me
know in the comments below and thank you
so much for watching and listening to my
scratchy voice please leave a like if
you're excited for videos to return to
the channel and subscribe if you haven't
already for much more gaming lore to
come huge thanks as always to my bandico
who make my day every day and are the
reason I returned to making videos if
you're interested in helping this
channel stay alive and grow feel free to
check out the many opportunities in the
description below well that's all I
wrote in this script so I guess this is
it follow me in my socials and I'll see
you next time this is Bandit signing out
peace
[Music]
foreign